hans a draw here against mvl a player
that you fought a lot in blitz how do
you feel going against them in classical
chess yeah we played this match in paris
so
i'm quite acquainted and we've played
many blitz matches under casual
circumstances
and under
we've played blitz matches in many
different settings with let's say unique
heading
so
you know it's safe to say that um
i am acquainted with
him
personally and his chess definitely much
more than other players here he
suppresses you a little bit doesn't use
his usual e4 which he tries to do as
most as possible in classical chess
instead we get this kind of grunfeld
disposition what were your thoughts
going into this variation yeah well
after the game i said you know when was
the last time playing outfit in glasgow
i said i couldn't remember
so he simply and and i think that is a
sign that
forgetting not to check knight f3 yeah
to to be honest i only looked it looked
at e4 and uh i
even i think we played
100 blitz games never
once has he not played of course it was
a surprise but so after knight of three
even on the first provided make such a
big decision right because there's so
many implications of the moon out of
three so first i'm trying to understand
okay
why not c4
um why not d4 y out of three and usually
when people start with f3
it means that they want to go g3
sometimes it means that they want to go
c4 without allowing e5 so i was trying
to sort of understand where things were
going so i could
sort of
understand
where i could avoid being put in a
position where i'm gonna be
forced to be precise right um and
obviously with a knight of three g3 it's
actually quite a dangerous system um
and uh so
there are a lot of ways that black can
actually go wrong and run into deep prep
so i went for the one thing i
uh knew think you didn't didn't expect
we let's just start after knight takes
d5 because this is the first moment i
want to talk about okay um so i actually
going for this line i i've never
checked this too deeply however there
was a game uh
the i think it was jokopian against
theodorum
pretty sure uh theodore was black around
hooker was white and it was in summer
chess classic and they made a quick draw
knight b5 bishop e6 95 bishop c8 so i
remembered following this quick draw and
i've seen i think this quick draw twice
so my conclusion was that it's probably
not that bad
and
my play seems pretty simple here i i
recalled something after knight c3
take take nice to three in this position
and usually after knight c6 these
positions that are that are symmetrical
sort of just lead to a lot of
just liquidation so i wasn't too worried
here right and he definitely
wasn't going to be able to fully punish
me because he had no idea how can he
expect this
or you know because when you play nf3 g3
you're doing a lot of work before the
game
and i don't even think he didn't have a
rest there he played the game yesterday
so yeah
uh regardless um this first quarter come
on knight be through is obviously an
interesting surprise um
and night before though it was the most
logical
um
he plays knight c3 knight c6 yeah
anticipate all of this bishop d2 was a
nice idea you know you want to
play a3 so bishop 5 rick c1
um
rick c8
a3 knight a6 now i was slightly worried
about the position but what i played is
an extremely concrete solution um i was
the 996 is a bit awkward
but
the standard b3 is also a bit awkward so
we've got this weird sort of
tension between these two knights
otherwise i thought that my bishop 105
was slightly better than the bishop on
d2
i guess they're opposite colors but
they're sort of the uh corresponding
bishops in this
very symmetrical structure
so when you play bishop e3
i thought bishop 6 was the only move
because i wanted to be extremely
concrete
take advantage of this week ninth and
uh he played queen c2 bishop f5
uh bishop b4 queen d7 and honestly if
you look at my time i like literally was
playing so quickly right i spent much
time in the opening so
with i just after yesterday i just
decided okay i'm just gonna
[Music]
i'm just gonna just gonna follow my
intuition just gonna play quickly and if
it goes wrong it goes wrong so uh this
this queen e6 like this
it's actually really interesting this
motif for the queen e6 and this specific
pressure i haven't seen before but
it's uh there's actually um
it's not a weird i've seen there's
in the specikov this is an idea and it's
completely different structure but i
thought that it was a really great
square because it's simultaneously okay
i guess the main problem okay if you
sort of look at compare the pieces right
you've got the the main issue in these
positions a lot of pieces is the queen
placement so the queen on c2 was a bit
off
like um
for example let's say instead of queen
g7 i played bishop takes e4 okay
um
this position but before right yeah yeah
so let's say
once the queen takes on e4 then
everything is ready to then do you want
is coming and my queen is very misplaced
yeah so the main sort of dynamic and an
issue was sort of uh solving the the
queen placement and if the queen
placement is solved with the landscape
bishops being traded uh the pressure
from my g7 bishop especially with the
weakness on b2 combined with a3 being
already included um i felt that
obviously the not on a6 isn't ideal and
could be dominated i didn't feel like uh
he could he had to be very direct at
least if he was gonna do anything and
okay with the game this gf5 idea is
obviously quite weird but
uh my bishop g7 is protecting very well
[ __ ] 23 is terrible and as we saw in
the game he had to play knight d4 where
you're not worried about anything else
in this position 95 crossed my mind and
we discussed this after the game so
there were just so many even i was just
struggling to make sense of this um
like i considered 94 but i was just wait
maybe i was like wait that's not there's
so many moves i was like even just
looking at this especially my head hurt
and uh i i was just like okay it was 94
94 then i'll think i don't know if i'd
land before maybe but but i was just
even struggling to just un like i'm
sorry but i cannot
like uh
you know
before
you know to play chess you need to be in
such a serene state you know
you need to sleep well
you need to not be on social media five
hours a day you need to like go to the
game with a clear mind and you need to
be like calm you have to pull a yasser
you have to you can't be like you know
have a million different things entering
your head at once and and uh even you
know before this wesley game i was still
actually just forced to draw because
playing chess on these conditions is
simply no one can can can do this
and i didn't do that and i pay the price
but you know
anyways i think
it happened but
after 95 i was this rick d8 we discussed
rook z8 and out of 4 queen e4 yeah and
there was also queen e5 as well but
queen e4 take take maybe you can arg
queen takes e4 fa4 let's say rook takes
d8 uh rick takes d8 let's say rook c2
maybe you can argue some slight pull but
i just think this bishop one g7 is so
strong and
there isn't really a direct
plan maybe f5 is a bit weak but i
thought oh no so there's rookie one rook
b1 here maybe yeah i just thought this
was actually fine for you uh perhaps
they were a little bit more worried
about this cool move rook d3 but it's of
course difficult to find rig d3 well
yeah
yeah i didn't consider rook t3 but uh
yeah rick d8 would probably be the most
natural continuation uh perhaps had some
hope for 94 but i don't think it was
working no i definitely yeah it
definitely wasn't yeah i i think that's
i think at least i knew that i was not
capable of calculating at all this game
you got to this position and you seemed
like if we were forced to calculate i
guess some of the races are so simple
like come on it's just so it's just easy
right what do you mean calculate like
like if you go back oh my all in those
are basically forced like if you can
suggest another canon move no no after
rook at five what what were your thought
processes what maybe rook desyncs yeah
i thought
the nice let's say there's rook d5 well
there's check right let's check it like
king f6 i didn't see
i don't i wasn't sure
where the queen
was
oh you can take
oh maybe am i getting mated wow that's
no you're not no you're not
wait but brook on d1 is hanging no with
check yes
and then i can i'm sorry is this like a
joke
like a prank like could i take the rook
like i'm sorry
it's it's just a draw it's just a draw
yeah okay
you're spending some time with too much
time with the computers
i'm i'm sorry like
i don't
i think this variation speaks for itself
like this is the
no but of course i saw um that rookie
six but i usually assume like if
frequencies is happening and i'm taking
a rook
and the rick and chief is hey i can't
imagine a situation where i'm losing so
that that wasn't i think that was a
logical way for me
i didn't i don't know if it was
necessary to calculate this far no and
then you made a very comfortable draw
after the move queen before did you feel
you would rather say yeah afterwards
were traded it's
just maybe i'm
white is to be preferred but yeah tell
us a little bit about your loss
yesterday uh they say that you learn a
lot from losses why would they say
this is true
they are they thou correct
um
uh i do learn a lot from my losses and
uh there was actually a period um where
i would never have like
non i would never draw like there was a
period i think when i was around 2500
that i went to a tournament it was seven
wins two losses next tournament was like
nine games one draw it was like five i
won four games in a row then i lost five
games in a row and the next tournament
so so
my style has become a bit more solid
but i've always i think losses are of
course a lot to learn from and there's
so much to learn from this game first of
all um
the pet trough was a unique uh surprise
of course i was still ready and i played
normally but i think that the the thing
that really should be learned especially
when you're playing guys against wesley
is that
uh risk aversion is i think a really
really important skill in chess and um
i think that if you look at someone like
wesley he's
he never i don't know if he
not he doesn't really blow people off
the board but he is just so so precise
so accurate and he simply never will
make a blunder or a mistake extremely
very rarely so
i think this is a conscious thing and
many points early on in this opening i
could have made decisions that would
maybe never lose the game right right
and
that is obviously a lesson to be learned
but considering the circumstances
like i don't think i need to even
verbalize the
the mental pressure and everything
that's going on like
maybe only i can understand this or
people who have been through similar
things but i assure you playing chess
doing something sitting there for five
hours trying to keep a clear head trying
to compete even i'm completely this is
my first super tournament of my life
so this is extremely it's extremely
difficult um
but you know i love trash and i'm just
enjoying playing
but i wouldn't be lying if i'm just
really hoping for this
i really just i i i can't play chess
anymore this is this is uh to play chess
under these conditions is absolutely
ridiculous can i say it's not bad to not
be able to play chess and still make a
draw against mvl with the black pieces
yeah but
of course uh mbl is also um having a
difficult tournament so maybe he wasn't
as
like i think mvl having a good
tournament would have played e4 and
things would have been much more
combative
but in this case uh based on the opening
and based on
the tournament situation i think that uh
it's a fine result and i think i played
pretty well i don't think i made syncope
mistakes and i didn't get into time
pressure for no reason like i have
in every in every game
hans we have a question from the
audience at least that's what our
producers have been telling us let's see
they're on the screen for hans given the
last couple of years of travel isolation
and now this drama do you have a support
network to lean on
from what do you mean by a support
network
i didn't write this question
i would i would i think that the wording
is just
maybe a group of people that would be
supporting well
you know people that you can go to well
i live a pretty isolated life um
to be honest i i
i
[Music]
and that's by choice
so
i will say that i have received
an insane amount of messages i think
every single person that i've ever met
or even played in chess has sent me a
message
and honestly all positive maybe one out
of 100 are negative
so
um at the early moments uh
when things were so when people were
saying these planning messages after my
first interview this was obviously
really
it was nice to see
and some articles written and obviously
that was supportive but in terms of
speaking to people
that's just my personal life so i don't
really care to to elaborate on that but
uh i have a very small
i just
it's
i like to play chess and i like to do
all things chess and uh
i have people that i i
there's certainly people that i trust
that's true and people that i've talked
to but
yeah you can you could say yes i
wouldn't say a
group or network but i would say a group
of people but
you know this situation has certainly
showed the true colors of many people
well hans thank you for joining us i
know that you have two more games that
you want to finish your first super
tournament on a high note so we'll let
you rest thank you yeah two two quick
questions for your hans first of all
how did you do in those blitz matches
that you mentioned with mvl when you
guys were yeah so combating yeah so i'll
talk i am so initially i was actually
i'll give context first i was um going
from armenia to germany for the
bundesliga and i got a few days to burn
so i was like why not go to paris
and um
they arranged the match and there was a
two-set match um we played i believe
three plus one
two
uh to six i believe
and then we played three three plus zero
to six as well he absolutely dominated
me in the first portion i think it was
something it was a huge scoring six one
but the second portion i won
then we played a four game tiebreaker
match that went 2-2
and then in the armageddon uh he beat me
but he was dead lost and and even he
will admit that but it was it was a
casual match it was actually a lot of it
was at this chess bar and there's huge
crowds as well after every game they
were clapping so it's quite a unique
format but uh
i definitely think if you ask mvl and
there's a video of this there's a full
video of this me playing blitz against
the world the world blitz champion and
almost beating him in a long match so
if you guys want to see my blitzkills
i'm sure you can find that video against
the as i repeat the world blitz champion
uh yes you had a second question yeah do
you have a coach do you have a somebody
you work with
do you have a coach
i don't uh yes uh but i would not like
to reveal the that's good enough for us
that's good enough yeah yeah is it good
i have coach advisor the term mentor you
know it's uh nice i have people
uh helping me uh i i decided after
yeah we're not really after maybe i
should get one
but actually you know uh yeah i would
actually like to first of all uh
uh pay tribute to to one of my first
coaches yasser you might know him john
grief yes and uh i was actually uh loved
in light of this entire situation i
would actually like to to to
actually speak about something because
now there's all the attention i'd like
to highlight someone very important um
when i was uh nine years old
i went to the uh
there was a coffee shop the i think was
the blue danube my dad would take me
there and these guys were like average
agent b60 and i was nine years old and
i'd go there and i'd play blitz against
them
um
just
every sunday and then it became multiple
times a week and i just play so much
bloods against these guys and one of the
people there knew john grief who wanted
to get me a coach and
my family couldn't afford working with
him so this guy sponsored
the lessons and i was actually the last
person to work with him before he passed
away and he had no family and i was one
of the only people to see him
before he passed away
and you know
a lot of my inspiration and my chess
passion came from him he was the u.s uh
champion
i think in 1971
he's played some beautiful games he beat
miguel night or if he's he uh but it was
a really sad story because uh he
uh he never had any money he couldn't
make a career from chess and uh as the
astroplayer knows back then becoming a
professional chess was very difficult so
i just like to to to shine some light on
on his amazing impact on my career and
uh and his legacy because i i don't want
that to be forgotten and i hope that
people remember him to be a great chess
player and he was a chess purist
absolutely you know he had health
problems and i'd go over for lessons and
he could barely walk but he was picking
me up a chocolate chip cookies and
lemonade and and he really loved chess
and i just like to honor him because
and all of this uh uh just on all this
drama and everything i just
if everyone's going to listen to me then
i'm going to at least talk about
something that's important to me
so that's beautiful thank you so much
for that
cons because indeed
i knew
john grief very well as you said a
former u.s champion and i remember we
drove down from edmonton to seattle and
we did it in one go we had one album
sergeant pepper's lonely hearts club
band we had this tape deck and we played
it over and over and over and over again
for seven and a half hours hums good
luck in the remaining games thank you so
much for your comments thank you thank
you absolutely yeah john grief that's
really really really nice to
to to get a shout out yeah he was a he's
a
good